Texas lawmakers are heading into a
special session today to again consider
restrictions on what bathroom
transgender people can use 14 Dallas
based businesses signed a letter to
fight the proposed legislation American
and Southwest Airlines along with AT&T
are just some of the companies that
argue it would hurt the state's ability
to attract new businesses and jobs David
Berg no is outside the Texas State
Capitol in Austin David good morning
Charlie good morning you've got what
estimates that says Texas could lose
five and a half billion dollars if these
bathroom bills become law look the real
fight here reflects what appears to be
going on with the GOP nationally in that
you've got moderate Texas Republicans
who are in a full-out fight with the far
right leaning members of their own party
when it comes to the issue of
transgender people using public
bathrooms in Texas the state's
Republican governor has voiced the
conservative party line we need a law
that protects the privacy of our
children in our public schools just like
two months ago during the regular
session the governor's agenda is facing
pushback on multiple fronts Saturday
transgender woman Ashley Smith posted
this photo with the governor with the
caption how will the potty police know
I'm transgender if the governor doesn't
it's also pitting Republican lawmakers
against each other the party's divided
over whether this is a deeply important
moral issue or just a complete fake with
no purpose except to rally the base
conservative state representative Ron
Simmons introduced HB 46 it could impact
transgender bathroom use in school
districts I need to know that I can have
the same expectation of privacy no
matter where I am in the state of Texas
if I'm using one of these facilities but
the Republican State House Speaker has
voiced his concern for these so-called
bathroom bills he was quoted in The New
Yorker as saying he was disgusted by all
of this it's absurd that bathroom bills
have taken on greater urgency in fixing
our school finance system he is pushing
back against the will of the governor
and lieutenant governor so you know it's
a concern last year protests and threats
of boycotts erupted
over a similar measure in North Carolina
which lawmakers were eventually forced
to roll back more than a dozen Texas
based CEOs have now signed an open
letter expressing their concern that the
legislation would hurt businesses
investment and jobs those sentiments
were echoed in a full-page ad taken out
by IBM on Friday we have trans employees
and we have families with trans children
and they're not feeling safe
by the way iBM has 10,000 employees in
the state of Texas viana as for that
representative I mentioned in our piece
I asked him how many people did you talk
to before you drafted this legislation
and he thought for a minute and then he
said quote I visited with myself it was
an idea that I had in quote and then he
admitted we probably all could have done
better at that interesting perspective
David thank you